欢迎各位说明今天这期百车圈说我是三刀。
最近这段时间呢，如果大家刷汽车圈的新闻，
那肯定看到过一条热搜啊，
就是八家车企，因为锁店被约谈。
那么今天这个选题呢，
我看到上一期的节目的评论区，
有人已经猜到了。
包括我们知识星球也有人在问，
说三刀你会不会聊这个事儿，
你敢不敢聊这个事儿，
你能不能去在节目里面去报道一下，
就到底是哪几家车企，
把个用户的店给锁了。
那么这个报道呢，
其实说的是有鼻子有眼的。
2026年的3月份，
全国12315平台关于新的原车OTA锁店的投诉突然暴增，
一个月超过1.2万件，
同比上涨273%，
那么最后呢，监管介入，
八家车企被约谈，
三家被立案调查，
两家是撤回了争议升级包，
并且承诺恢复性的。
那么我为什么说这个说的有鼻子有眼呢，
大家一听就明白了，
这就很明显，
这个就是一个假新闻嘛。
那网上还流传着，
就是说这个八家车企的名单，
分别是比亚迪，
特斯拉，
小鹏,
理想,
未来,
问戒,
极客,
和爱安。
结果这个新闻一出来之后，
各家在官方渠道，
不管是微博，
公众号，
举各个平台，
赶紧去辟谣，
说没有，
以法务的身份来担保，
我们没有接到过任何的调查。
那么网上也有相关的图，
今天其实在网上搜你也能搜到，
这个图呢，
很明显是用AI做出来的，
所以现在这个AI的时代，
我觉得有点乱，
有点乱，
不管是图片还是视频还是什么的，
反正这个一甲乱真了，
几乎是可以说一甲乱真了，
前段时间我看那个NBA的，
现场导播切的那个镜头，
连我都以为那个画面，
你根本就看不出是假的，
一个大美女啊，
身材非常好，
那个镜头给了她很长时间，
我也是转到我的微博，
我说这个NBA现在的导演这个，
很有水准，
审美很有水准，
和调侃了一下，
然后下面的评论区都是，
道哥AI, AI,。
你看不出来是AI吗？
所以这新闻怎么说呢，
连视频都判断不出来，
这新闻还仅仅是张图片，
你说谁能判断得出来呢？
而且你想想看，
就造谣一张嘴，
那下面这些车骑都跑断腿啊，
对吧,
他们的公关啊，
法务啊，
都要出来去澄清，
说自己没有被约谈，
那么最后呢是，
中国汽车工业协会的副秘书长，
叫柳燕，
柳副会长，
那么副秘书长，
还不能说他的职位说错啊，
副秘书长，
他呢就说这个网传的相关，
监管约谈，立案信息，
军委不实信息，
与事实严重不符，
相关的主管部门，
并没有就网传的这个，
锁电相关事宜，
开展任何的约谈，
包括还有立案啊，
这些什么监管执法行动，
那么后来呢央视网，
也出来跟证了一下表述，
因为央视网之前也是发了，
就是跟了相关的新闻，
然后他说这个，
从2020年至今，
确实有一些车骑，
因为异常加速，
电池起火，
OTA等问题，
被约谈或者是调查，
但是不是最近这一次，
因为锁电的原因，
集中约谈罢假，
所以他也是出来批这个谣了啊，
那么这个消息出来之后呢，
你说大家是什么反应的，
其实大家并不关心这个消息是真是假，
只不过大家对于锁电这件事情，
一直有所听闻，
如果这些消息是真的，
对吧,
如果是这个企业这个品牌被坐实了，
那绝对是一大污点，
但是即使这个新闻是假的，
那么大家其实心里面也有数，
新的原车被锁电这个事情，
肯定是存在的，
只不过很难被证明，
那么新的原车主其实也很敏感，
就是说我原来买游车，
对吧,
发动机是你讲好的功率扭矩，
编速箱也是弹好的，
8AT,
还是9AT,
还是双厘盒，
对吧,
这些所有的性能全部都是弹好的，
邮箱、多大机都是弹好的，
但是现在买电车，
买电车看起来电池包是我的，
电机也是我的，
但是这个电池能不能充满，
能不能放干，
快充的功率能不能给到顶，
输出的这个洞里能不能彻底的给我这个放开，
很多时候不是我说了算，
或者说他今天给到我的是这个，
那可能下个月OTA一升级，
他又变成另外一辆车，
对吧,
这些数据都有可能会变，
所以说这个数据到底谁说了算，
我有没有知情权，
我有没有选择权，
这个其实是最关键的一件事情，
所以很多人在网上一听到锁电这两个字，
就为什么会炸，
炸的点就在于，
其实他他他我觉得大多数人是感觉就是，
第一个就是你不尊重我，
第二个就是你没有让我有知情权，
然后第三就是没有让我选择，
就是厂家而且甚至于有点欺骗的成分，
因为大家可以看到就是OTA的这个说明里面，
基本上都是优化了什么，
优化了什么，
哎,
我有的时候就在想，
我车子开的好好的，
我需要你优化吗？
哎,
我就想不通了，
你能给我优化什么呢？
我有的时候也是不太理解，
他上面写的比方说，
叫做修复了某些什么，
什么设计安全的bug，
或者说是什么优化了某些，
什么核心部件的性能，
他也不跟你说得很清楚，
所以这就是我觉得很奇葩的一件事情，
那个OTA的安装包一看也不小，
所以你就不知道他到底是真的优化了，
还是说是从我的这个腰包里面偷偷的把我一些权益拿走了，
或者说是给我做了一些限制，
所以说网上大家对这个就是限电这件事情特别的敏感，
我觉得他的敏感点真的不是说少了几十公里续航的问题，
而是说我花了钱我买了一块电池，
而且你还分标准续航版和长续航版，
我多花了几万块钱我去买那个长续航版，
但是OTA之后他直接缩水，
对吧,
你说是为了安全，
但有很多人其实不理解，
就是你的限电和安全这两个字，
到底是怎么关联，
有很多人是不了解这个东西的，
我一会儿展开来去讲，
你说是为了保护电池，
其实懂的人是理解的，
但是问题是即使懂，
但是你没有提前告诉我，
你没有让我选择，
对，你没有把相关的影响去讲得很清楚，
那么今天这个节目呢，
其实我也不想去跟风在网上跟大家一起说，
和大大啥啥说，
这些车企都是非常积贼，
我也不会去为某些车企去洗地，
我觉得说OTA是正常的，
我也不会去洗地，
我觉得我们想聊的是什么，
就是新闻肯定是假的，
这就不用说了，
对吧,
就是什么八家车企的名单这些都是假的，
但是真的是什么，
真的就是车企通过OTA去改变车辆性能，
这个是新能源时代，
现在绕不开，
你将来也绕不开这件事情，
哪怕今后就算是什么固态电池这些，
你也绕不开，
所以车跟手机，
虽然说像，
但是其实也有不像的地方，
我举个例子，
你说手机更新完之后，
你发现变卡了，
你最多觉得说它就，
它可能是对吧，
给你施加了一点小谋法，
你本来用的好好的，
但是OTA就不行，
但是你手机不用你可以换，
那不值钱，几千块钱的东西，
你用了一两两三年之后更不值钱，
可能就一千块钱几百块钱了，
但是这个车不一样，
车改完之后你不可能说换就换，
少则十来万的车，
多则都是几十万的车，
你再换下一辆的话，
你不可能说换的更差，
你肯定想换的更好，
对不对，
你车的参数被改了，
你说我到底是正常使用之后，
它正常的衰减，
还是说我明明我的车，
其实性能各方面还是可以的，
比方说到了五六年，
到了七八年之后，
哎，就感觉怎么用用就不行了，
续航不行了，
充电不行了，
所以这个就是大家觉得很，
就很不爽的一个点，
七八年之后的电车真的有，
有那么那么的拉跨梦，
可能不至于，
你看我们上次去说那个，
吉利地毫EV450，
那个我估计大概率是没有限电，
车主说他的车开了八年，
最后的衰减也就是15%左右，
就是他自己测算出来的，
下面的评论区很多人都讲不可能，
八年15%,
那吉利的这个电池，
电控那做的厉害了，
但是人家车主自己就是这么算了呀，
他觉得那个车到现在开，
正常也没什么问题呀，
是不是，
然后那天我看到还有个评论区，
说之前买了个江淮的电车，
所以虽然讲那个电车续航也不行，
这个也不行，
但是开起来也没问题呀，
正常开，
但他最后还是卖掉了，
好，我们还是来讲一讲这个今天的主题，
就是什么是锁电，
锁电其实说白了就是车企通过OTA远程升级，
或者说你到店里面去保养，
它可以直接通过它的电脑踏到你的车上，
通过OBD直接给你进行更新，
这都是很简单的一个事，
那么它所谓的更新，
你也可以说是升级，
你也可以说是修改，
修改你车上的电池管理系统的参数，
那么这个电池管理系统呢，
平时大家在买车的时候能看到，
叫BMS,
BMS相当于就是你这个电池包的大脑，
它决定这块电池能冲到什么程度，
能放到什么程度，
我们知道电池是充电放电吗，
充放电，
冲到什么程度，
放到什么程度，
什么时候限制功率，
什么时候保护电池，
那么你可以把它理解成一个水桶，
就可能这样你要抽象联想，
就是它是个水桶，
那么厂家一开始你买的时候，
告诉你这个水桶能装100升的水，
那么结果你开着开着开着，
开了几年之后，
你的仪表盘上显示的还是，
你这个车是100%的充满电了，
但是实际上你会发现，
它这个电池或者说这个水桶，
它装的其实不是100升，
它现在装90升，
然后仪表其实就是叫做快乐表，
就是一个快乐表，
让你感觉快乐，
说CRTC续航600公里，
你的车充满电就是600公里，
真的吗，
可能吗，
所以这个600公里就是充到100%，
那个100%我觉得也不一定是100%，
反正就是充满了，
你充了一夜了，
好，那你就是600公里的续航，
所以都得要自己去二次换算，
开了久了之后，
凭经验去算，
我的车的600实际能开个450，
然后我现在开到个70%，
就还剩30%的时候，
我再算一下这450，
30%,
我都还能开120，
120,
有人讲都这么麻烦吗，
其实也没有那么麻烦，
我现在基本上就撑一二，
就是比方说我的车还剩100公里续航，
你看我今天我从家到机场，
我单程大概是50公里，
来回100公里，
我的车现在就是，
我走的时候续航大概270公里，
那不出意外的话，
明明想想能开到家，
因为我出差就，
这一次到北京就一天时间，
如果说我要出差这一次，
三个晚上，
比方说四天三晚，
我不敢这么开，
因为你放到里面，
它会正常掉一点电，
上次我就差一点点，
就就就就趴在路上了，
对吧,
所以我有可能路上，
我会在某个服务区，
再去充个电，
或者就是干脆在我那个机场旁边的，
就是老隔的那个停车场，
那个停车场非常好，
非常方便，
它连有充电桩，
有的时候就是我比方说，
如果我是带我的卡片钥匙，
我可以直接丢给它，
车快没电了，
我说老隔你帮我正常充一点电，
充完之后再给我停到车位上，
没有任何问题啊，
这个老师傅人真的非常的好，
我下次把我的这个，
那个叫什么，
实体电卡放到里面，
哎呦,
你这么一讲，
我都忘了我那个实体的电卡放哪了，
就是我那个解锁的卡，
所以你看我平时都用手机解锁，
你现在一下让我去找我那个卡片解锁，
我还真记不得放到什么地方了，
我们继续聊这个话题啊，
其实这件事情我觉得一点也不复杂，
其实说白了就是，
厂家就是为了让这个电池的衰减变慢，
因为什么呢，
因为今年是二零二六年，
很多事情我觉得都是跟时间相关，
二零二六年你想一想，
二零一八年前后，
其实一七年前后就差不多，
国内的这个新的原车就开始爆发了，
一八年一九年就开始，
你在路上能看到非常多的新的原车，
那么现在是八年，
马上就要过八年，
过八年有什么问题呢，
就是国家其实对于当时的这个三电治保，
特别是这个电池的治保，
当时有一定的要求，
就比方说大家都知道，
八年十二万公里，
一般都是不低于八年十二万公里，
那么乘用车的核心部件最贵的，
其实就是这个电池，
你说电机这些东西其实都不存在那么贵啊，
那么对于车企来讲，
老的电车的电池，
那么八年之后，
第一个它出了宝了，
第二个它的这个衰减，
故障锁培，
一旦要是，
一个两个它还能可能私下解决，
一旦要是大规模的出现，
第一个，
肯定是会增加非常大的收获成本，
第二个，
那么这肯定也是一个负面新闻，
因为现在人人都是自媒体嘛，
大家至少会有个抖音，
小红书什么的，
是吧,
也会有微信群啊，
那么会形成一个负面事件，
所以这件事情如果说你不管，
你任由它就正常的衰减，
然后任由它正常去锁培，
你当年承诺的吗，
八年十二万公里，
那么不仅仅是从真金白银上来讲，
厂家要掏很多钱，
那么另外它是一个，
相当于是个负资产，
对于它的这个，
不管是品牌的名气也好，
名声也好，
它是个负资产，
所以,
这就倒逼车企，
我们讲就比方说，
有人比方在一些公共场合，
他把手机放在桌子上面，
你想我打篮球，
经常就会看到，
哇，各种什么，
iPhone 10G Pro Max,。
就往球场旁边一扔，
有的我认识的人，
我就跟他提醒，
我说是这样子的，
这个地方本身是一个，
就是公共空间，
对吧,
公共空间，
虽然有监控，
但是你把你这个手机，
一万多块钱的东西，
往这边一放，
就是不怕贼偷，
就怕贼惦记着，
那这个其实也是一样的道理，
就是车企它是完全可以，
自主的通过软件策略，
让电池进入一种，
就是更加的保守，
更加的偷懒的一个状态，
那你说它的，
你说它的这个，
初中是不是好的呢，
就是让电池减缓摔减，
减缓摔减，
初中是好的，
但是这个动机，
这个动机到底是为你，
车主好，
还是为了它，
不要再给你在过质宝之后去锁培，
为了让自己不要有负面新闻，
这个东西有的时候你说不清，
这个问题有的时候你没办法去解释，
它把电池充电上线压一压，
放电的深度收一收，
这个充电的功率，
或者说是这个电机的功率，
输出给你控一控，
那这个电池，
对这个电池来讲，
肯定是衰减，
会更舒服一些，
寿命肯定会更长一点，
检测出来的这个健康度，
肯定也是不会那么难看，
但是对于用户来讲代价是什么呢？
就是续航变短了，
动力变弱了，
充电变慢了，
然后车的体验整体就缩水嘛，
所以锁电我觉得最根本的问题点，
是在于就是不知情，
而且没有选择，
比方讲如果厂家，
他说我现在要给你进行OTA了，
但是我这次OTA升级之后，
你的续航有可能会少50公里到80公里，
你的充电速度，
可能上线，
好比说从120的120千瓦，
然后现在降到个，
比方说降少一点，
比方讲80，
对吧,
上线是80，
你平时想一想，
我家里面慢充7000瓦，
也没什么好说的，
那我在外面去快充的话，
加门口的充电桩，
能拉到120、130，
这个也很少见，
基本上也就是50、60、70千瓦，
就是基本上就这样，
他说给你降了，
那你觉得OK，
那就降呗，
对不对，
我愿意降啊，
我愿意OTA啊，
因为我的使用环境，
基本上也达不到你限制之后的上线，
我是愿意的，
但有的人就不愿意啊，
我无所谓啊，
你管我呢，
我的车子天生过一年，
我就卖了，
我现在就要充电效率高，
我就要它的动力性能好，
我无所谓，
所以这个你给我一个这种，
就是叫做，
应该叫什么叫风险告知，
你给我签署，
我愿意签我就签，
哎，电子板不就行了吗？
就这个电子板是不可以忽略的，
你就不能点差，
你必须看完，
而且你必须点接受，
或者不接受，
你就强制给它两个选项，
不就行了吗？
搞那么复杂干什么呢？
我孤差啊，
后期的厂家大概率会怎么做，
大概率会怎么做，
因为你它这样做的话，
可以归逼风险啊，
是不是，
它可以归逼风险，
所以现在的电动车，
肯定比早期的电动车要好，
早期的电动车，
或者说新能源车，
它的电池技术啊，
热管理水平，
BMS策略,
都不像现在那么成熟，
所以说过了几年之后，
你特别是在一些这种，
因为你不知道每个人的用车环境，
有些极端的用车环境，
它有可能会增加故障风险，
甚至包括安全隐患，
所以车企，
你说在8年之后，
快要过质宝的时候，
去通过OTA，
收紧它的电池策略，
延缓它的衰减，
控制它的用力安全，
你说能理解吗？
我觉得也能理解，
也能理解，
但是问题就是，
这台车子是我花钱买的，
你不能把所有的这些问题点，
你说包装成一具，
我厂家都是为你好，
那这厂家为我好，
那你能不能，
你把我的性能各方面，
包括充电效率各方面减免，
减掉之后，
你返钱给我，行不行？
你返钱给我，
你说我给你这个延缓，
但是我给你性能缩减，
我给你凡两万块钱，
这两万块钱你还可以去买我们家下一辆车，
我觉得这也是一个方案，
对不对？
我觉得这也是个方案，对吧？
性能缩减，
又不用索赔了，
把你索赔的那个成本，
直接贴不给你，
老车主区换下一辆车，
我觉得这也行，
这也行，
但是厂家一般不会这么做，
大概率不会这么做，
但是如果说，
厂家什么都不说，
就是默默的在OTA里面，
然后用刚刚我讲的什么优化，
升级,
这些莫力良可的，
或者说是包装的这些画素，
然后怎么讲呢？
你也没有办法不升，
现在有人，
厂家推OTA的升级套件，
你不升吗？
升级包发过来，
你不升，
没有啊，都升啊，
就是你升完之后，
你发现你的续航短了，
你的动力弱了，
你的充电变卖了，
然后你去问社会，
社会说这些都是正常的，
没有任何问题，
是你的使用环境，
说天气温度变低了，
说你有没有跑高速啊，
你有没有跑烧成功路啊，
谁开车天天在路上，
就30码20码的开啊，
那正常多少也是，
有一段时间的速度拿上来，
开个七八十，
开个一百多啊，
你说我开了，
哦，你开了，
你开了那就是正常的，
为什么呢，
电动车高速的时候能耗高，
是不是，
有没有下雨天开啊，
那废话，
那谁还晴天开，
下雨天不开车，
有啊,
哦,
那下雨天的能耗高，
那你没有经常爬坡啊，
去山路啊，
那不讲废话嘛，
那车子买回来天天放到那个地方，
不开吗，
那周末总得带家人去自驾游啊，
那自驾游有的时候有些盘山公路啊，
有些上坡路段，
这不正常吗，
那这个是你的问题，
那这个就能耗高啊，
对吧,
你以前能耗低的时候，
那都是开的平路，
你现在这个能耗高的都是雨天，
都是上坡啊，
都是这些不好的环境，
高速公路，
所以这东西人嘴两张皮，
都是由他讲，
那这个问题点，
它怎么解决呢，
或者我们这么讲嘛，
就是这个问题，
我们如何去发现，
然后如何去维权，
那这个是大家应该非常关心的点，
其实我觉得啊，
比这个更恶性的还有一种什么事啊，
就是硬件全部给到位了，
但是软件，
它不给你解锁，
这个我节目里面曾经提到过，
但是现在这个品牌都开始，
这个就是不要你掏钱了，
估计也是被骂惨了，
而且销量也不怎么样，
然后开始怎么操作，
就是之前我讲的smart精灵一号，
前牌做一家热，
一千两百九十九，
永久解锁，
后牌做一家热，
一千九百九十九，
永久解锁，
方向盘加热，
方向盘加热分三个包，
九十九包月，
两百九十九包年，
九百九十九，
是永久解锁，
然后上面我讲的前牌后牌跟方向盘加热，
全套解锁，
一次性负，
四千三百块钱，
这个方案我可以讲是，
前无古人，
后无我估计也没有来者了，
因为我记得本池是EQS还是EQS吧，
当时后轮转向要钱嘛，
而且特别搞笑就是国外收的费用跟国内收的费用还不一样，
一个后轮转向，
硬件都给你上了，
但是软件不给你解锁，
这个是最恶心的，
你比起这个来讲的话，
我觉得OTA比它稍微好一点，
比它稍微好一点，
其实今天讨论这个问题点，
本质上来讲并不是说什么续航少多少，
就是权利边界的问题，
车企和车主之间，
大家互相在，
不能叫争夺嘛，
因为你根本就没有争夺的权利，
就是你到底是在维护安全，
还是你在转价成本，
你是在优化体验，
还是在掩盖问题，
你是把用户当车主，
还是把用户当成，
对吧,
我跟车一样是远程可以控制的那么一个中端设备，
所以今天这个节目我觉得真的不用去关心到底是哪几家车企，
这个新闻铁定已是假的了，
因为这么多的官媒已经出来是去做实它了，
而我们觉得应该是了解这个背后的事，
因为这件事情本质上来讲，
它不代表没有，
它一定是有的，
而且这件事情背后，
如果一旦是遇到的话，
你的知情权和你的，
或者说叫做你对于你的这个车辆的控制权，
你怎么维权是非常关键的一个事，
锁电有人讲说是违法，
其实锁电这件事情违不违法，
我觉得分两块来讲，
如果说，
车企它发现电池存在安全隐患，
然后通过正规的召回程序，
通过充分的告知，
然后通过相关部门的备案审批，
对这个车辆的什么安全防护各方面它做一些解释，
这个逻辑我觉得是成立的，
因为它相关部门已经给它批了嘛，
但是问题是你要如果在车主不知情，
不确认，不选择的情况下，
你说我把你的电池电量啊，
相关容量包括充电的功率，
放电的功率，
还有动力输出我都给你改了，
这肯定是不行的，
其实这两年相关的那个大家都知道工薪部对吧，
它也出了一些规定，
工薪部我记得是在2021年就出过相关的文件，
当然就是说车企在做在线升级的时候，
就必须要具备安全影响评估，
还有就是测试验证，
还有包括实施保障，
信息记录等功能，
所以它要向用户去告知升级的目的，
包括内容时常注意事项和升级结果，
那么到了2025年的时候呢，
工薪部和市场经济管理总局就是事件局，
又把这个事情进一步的收紧了一下，
要求车企实施OTA升级备案，
还记得吗，
去年有好几家车企一直说，
什么几月份推送OTA一直没推，
什么原因，
就是去年2025年刚刚开始实施这个规定，
就是OTA升级要求备案，
那么工薪部里面备案的这个时间，
就把他们这个之前的推送时间给打乱了嘛，
就延期了嘛，
那这里面涉及到产品主要技术参数的一些变更，
就必须要取得产品变更许可并且完成备案，
你才能去推送OTA，
所以这个我觉得相关部门已经开始接入进来了，
所以这个新闻一开始出来的时候，
我也是心里面百思不得其解，
我说你跟他约谈什么呢，
OTA升级这不都是去年2025年就已经开始走备案制度了嘛，
都是备案被挖案的东西，
推送出去了，
然后现在出现了很多的抱怨，
你再去约谈车企，
你这不应该约谈车企啊，
你这个应该约谈，
不能多说，
说了嘛，
这节目又要瞎瞎了，
是不是，
所以我们讲翻译成大白话就是，
就是厂家不能用软件来掩盖硬件问题嘛，
但是相关的这个主管的部门，
他们在审核备案的过程中，
那也要严谨啊，
对不对，
那他你要能查出来说，
你是在逃避这个召回的责任，
你就不能让他去OTA推送完，
那么既然你有审查的这一步，
那么推送出去了出了问题，
你反过来再去找车企去谈话，
对吧,
这个这个，
真正要应该怎么谈呢，
对不对，
怎么谈就不用我教育嘛，
对吧,
这个我相信，
你肯定比我们这些主播要专业，
是吧,
所以锁电真正的问题点，
我觉得不是电池是保护这个事情本身，
是程序不透明，
而且权力不对等，
还有包括责任不清楚，
但是有些事情就是说到点刀就为止了，
那这个事情也不是我能解决的，
大家就明白，
反正就是说，
锁电的时候把参数藏在后台里面，
卖车的时候讲性能，
出车的时候讲安全，
锁配的时候讲自然衰减，
对吧,
平时宣传案是放在海报上，
就是啊这些参数都给你看到，
那么车主一维权一切都正常，
这个逻辑消费者肯定是承受不了的嘛，
接受不了的嘛，
是不是，
怎么维权，
我就说个结论吧，
一个字难，
两个字很难，
其实我想讲的是根本就维不了，
为什么这么讲呢，
你说怎么维权，
你论上讲当然是可以了，
对吧,
车旗做一个什么升级说明，
然后呢提供升级前后的技术变化，
告诉你说啊，
他要,
你说我要恢复性能，
你现在，
就是你给我升的是2.2.0版本，
我现在恢复成1.0行不行，
你可以要求没问题，
但是到今天为止，
我还没有见过哪个车主，
有从新版本刷回老版本的，
去CS店,
去这个刷老版本，
好像有过，
但是极其极其少，
我记得阿维塔有一次是因为什么原因啊，
当时收货就问我说要不要刷回老版本，
我当时我还愣了一下，
我说刷老版本，
为什么要刷老版本，
那什么原因我忘了，
能刷肯定是能刷，
但是没有人这么干啊，
谁会愿意这么干的，
那我想问，
那现在2.0刷回到1.0版本，
那将来3.0你升不升呢，
那4.0你升不升呢，
那3.0是不是从2.0基础上升上去的呢，
4.0是不是3.0基础升上去的呢，
这这个问题点我觉得就很有意思了，
你说维权你怎么维，
关键还有个问题就是，
他的这个OTA升级，
他是一个黑盒子里面的，
我们讲叫黑盒教父，
什么叫黑盒教父，
就是过程你看不到，
BMS的参数你是永远拿不到的，
不管是升级前的还是升级后的，
这些后台数据你根本拿不到，
你只是感受到猜测，
就觉得我的车好像是续航变短了，
加速好像不太给力，别慢了，
车好像不太好用，
但是你怎么证明他是因为被锁电，
你怎么拿到这个BMS的数据你拿不到的，
你不能说证明说各种各样的因素影响，
就一定是厂家的锁电，
你管讲的温度啊，跑高速啊，
包括驾驶习惯啊，
雨天啊，山路啊，这些都有可能啊，
还包括你快充的多还是慢充的多，
电池的自然衰减这些，
所以你维权难度非常高，
它不是一个直接的导向原因，
你也拿不到一个直接的证据，
你更别说拿什么证据链了，
从A到B，从B到C，
最后推倒出来，
就是你OTA的问题变，
所以怎么讲呢，
这个问题真的不是我们老百姓能搞得定的，
个人维权你面对企业，
信息不对称，
这不是一般二般的不对称，
是极其不对称，
所以我觉得这个事情最终还是什么，
只能从源头上，
监管部门把这个OTA被按，
监管部门把这个OTA看清楚了，
研究明白了，
然后再推从轨车主，
只能是从这个地方来解决，
对吧,
所以这个东西，
你如果相关监管部门你不管，
那就很难了，
所以撤起每一次升级到底改什么，
它影响了什么，
谁批准的，
谁被按的，
谁负责，
这留下记录嘛，
真的出了问题，
你就相关的去追溯嘛，
是不是，
所以一句话总结就是说，
锁电如果说是公开的，
合规的，
安全照回的一部分，
那我觉得是可以的，
但如果是偷偷的，
强制的，
是模糊告知，
甚至,
它还把它包装成一种，
什么给我的好处优化，
实际是让我的权益缩水，
那对不起，
这件事情，
我觉得消费者的权益确实，
包括车主的权益确实是被侵犯了，
绝对不是手机的那套玩法，
绝对不是，
因为,
说句实在话，
你比方说我本来是一个600许航的车子，
现在我能，
新车开到个，
我们就算450到500吧，
你过个五六年之后，
它自然衰减可能衰减一部分，
你再帮我锁电锁个百分之二十，
我现在只能开300多，
那我肯定是不接受的，
那我300多，
那旁边那个车子，
当时买的比我还便宜，
也是600公里许航，
或者它甚至它就500公里许航，
它现在跑的甚至比我的300多还要多，
那那我能接受吗，
我二手市场上我的车不值钱啊，
是吧,
那影响的可能是几千，
甚至可能是几万块钱啊，
所以本质上来讲就是个问题点，
所以你都怎么办呢，
这真的没有什么好的办法，
你要说怎么办，
那我只能告诉你，
留证据啊，
你就拼命的留证据，
从你买回来第一天开始，
第一天有点夸张了，
就是你可能从一个，
你感觉你的车稍微有一点点，
这种,
啊,
续航下滑的时候，
那你就开始要记录啊，
那你不管是用小本本去记，
还是用一些什么相关的软件去记，
啊，OTA升级前，
升级后的软件版本，
升级时间，
啊,
满电的表现续航，
实际的续航达成率，
就是你实际的续航里程，
然后包括你的充电装的记录，
充了多少度电，
哪一天充的，
下次充电是什么时候，
充到百分之几，
充电功率的曲线，
充电的电量，
天气温度，
天压的情况，
还有包括驾驶路线，
所以你干脆你就，
你就养成一个这个，
写日记的习惯，
你就每天写日记，
哎,
你以后你说你看，
日记不会说谎，
我可以对天发誓，
啊,
我可以欺骗所有人，
但是我不会欺骗我自己，
我写日记的时候是面对我的内心，
啊,
所以我可以向天发誓，
我的日记上没有一个，
没有一个字是假的，
你看你在法庭上，
你拿出你的日记本，
你能不能把这个厂家，
这个官司给打赢，
所以我真的不知道该怎么说，
这件事你除了拿证据，
你看那怎样，
那有人想说，
那找第三方检测，
第三方检测他也拿不到底层的BMS的参数，
他最多能检测什么呢，
能检测电池的实际的可用容量，
电池的健康度，
充放电的相关表现，
而且有个问题点，
这个第三方，
你如果不是法院指定第三方，
他不一定认啊，
你一顿操作稳如虎，
花了二万五，
最后测出来这个报告拿到法庭上，
法庭说，
对不起，
第三方这个我不认，
我现在指定你一个，
我给你两家让你选，
这两家我们是法庭认可，
他的这个相关的检测报告可以当证据，
你结果一顿操作又是猛如虎，
又花两万五，
最后官司没打赢，
对吧,
你可能你的车残值还不值这点钱，
我就随口说说啊，
电视检测可能没有那么贵啊，
所以有维权这件事情我觉得真的很难，
很难,
非常难，
所以你说那怎么办呢，
那怎么办，
其实也不是没有办法，
通过你的社交媒体嘛，
你社交媒体你怎么发呢，
你也不要说你的车出什么问题了，
你就问，
你同样内情的车，
同样年份去买的有没有，
如果有的话，
你现在的车的续航是多少，
你当成一个讨论帖，
在评论区里面跟大家去互动，
这个帖子在网上很多，
有很多，
特别是七八年的老车主，
那么你去讨论，
你找到这些，
当年跟你一起买这种同型号的车型，
现在他们的车子也出现了明显的这个电视车件，
那实际上就是锁电嘛，
而且他们都是在，
比方说几几年，
几月份OTA之后，
就明显感觉车辆的续航上不去了，
那不就是锁电嘛，
是不是，
那么这个时候你们就一起打，
12315,
一起打市场监督局，
市场监管部门的相关电话，
包括像工薪部的相关的投诉渠道，
一起去投诉什么车制网这些东西，
一个人不行，
两个人不行，
你十个人吗，
一百个人呢，
五百个人行不行，
对不对，
你一个人就单独的个体事件，
这个叫什么偶发性故障，
那你十个人呢，
十个人可能是批词问题，
那一百个人呢，
那五百个人呢，
那就是个群体的维权事件，
监管部门，
它不是说看不见，
只不过一个两个是一个两个的处理方式，
对吧,
一千个，
五百个是一千个五百个的处理方式，
所以走司法渠道的成本是最高的，
精力是耗的最多的，
而且效果还不一定是最好的，
但是你走一个媒体的渠道，
走一个投诉给监管部门的渠道，
会相对来讲好一点，
有一点可能性，
哎,
怎么说呢，
反正这个我觉得维权很难，
所以车企它不是怕你生气，
它是怕你们一起生气，
这个很关键，
所以怎么说呢，
现在是这个软件定义汽车的时代，
对吧,
你说这个行动员现在越来越普及，
是个好事，
但也不一定是个好事，
越来越智能化是个好事，
你真的能用到那么多东西吗？
你真的能用到那么多的功能吗？
前两天我想买一块这个，
苹果的这个手表，
iWash,
我实在想去，
我这个表我也不少了，
对吧,
不管是卡修的，
还是说那种穿正装的这种皮表带的，
皮表带的机械表，
还是说这种滑翔北的，
小米的电子表，
智能手表我都有，
但是我现在想，
我这个苹果手机有一天我不小心，
我打开了那个软件，
我到现在我都不知道，
iPhone既然还有个软件，
就名字就叫Wash，
我打开这个Wash之后呢，
我就开始看它这里面的一些功能，
我觉得说这么好的一个苹果的iPhone手机，
我不去买一块手表，
它不完善啊，
那这个手机的功能其实有一部分软件给到我的体验啊，
那不等于就浪费了嘛，
然后呢我有一次路过这个苹果店，
我还去试带了一下，
分什么42的表盘，
46的表盘，
我就想买那个S11嘛，
那个Ochua太大了，
兔子带的就是Ochua，
太大了，
我也没有什么野外，
也没有什么这种什么徒步啊，
也没有这种需求，
S11我带了一下，
我就感觉我这个手腕比较细，
46有点大，
42呢,
也有点太小，
太秀气，
我就很纠结这个事情，
它这个表带还分什么SN，
还是什么NM啊，
就是分大和小嘛，
我也不知道我到底应该怎么带，
有人讲说测量一下你的手腕，
然后我基本上现在定下来应该是46，
然后就是SN，
我就很纠结，
我就讲题外话了啊，
因为节目已经到尾声了，
你就当我唠叨啊，
我当我就很纠结，
第一个，
这个表到底有什么功能对我，
真的有吸引力的，
我觉得无非就是几个，
第一个，
我可能我不用看手机，
我就可以通过手表看一些微信什么的，
我就不用总是掏手机了，
因为手机一掏，
除了看微信，
马上立刻就开始打开其他软件，
但手表上不会嘛，
就强制你不看手机，
微信上该回回，
回完之后不打开手机，
手机无非就是微信回一回，
你还能干什么呢，
对吧,
叮叮回一回嘛，
回回消息嘛，
就这两个软件，
其实我还要发微补，
这个也是我经常要用到手机的地方，
好,
那么其次是什么，
就是我的心率，
那有人讲三道理心脏不好，
不是,
我心脏很好，
就是因为，
像我打球有的时候，
我的状态不是特别好的时候，
就是可能我的，
就是心肺被拉爆了嘛，
可能我遇到一个人，
他强度比我高，
他总是被打我，
所以我可能会把表带过去，
然后我中间我有休息的时候，
我会测一下，
然后呢，
我会用一些方式让我的心率，
经常快速的把他降下来，
这样的话，
我的命中率更高，
我的整体的身体技能会更好一点，
所以心率对于我来讲，
还是比较重要的一件事情，
我觉得他测心率是很准的嘛，
那还有就包括测睡眠，
因为我，
睡眠质量是很好，
我自认为还是很好，
因为我不经常做梦什么的，
到头就睡，
只不过睡的有的时候比较晚，
大家看到我的节目，
经常有的时候凌晨更新，
是吧,
然后早上有参加活动，
可能一下要早起，
睡眠的时候就不足，
如果是没什么事，
正常休息嘛，
那我就正常八个小时睡眠，
没什么问题啊，
但是,
你要是参加活动，
你像今天我就录音录完之后，
明天早上是八点四十集合，
那我今天可能就只能睡个，
可能就五个小时左右吧，
五个小时，
所以然后戴个表，
我就给自己个提醒，
看到这边都不达标，
不达标，不达标，
那我就可能给自己个压迫感，
那我总得要想办法要达标一下是吧，
那想着想去不就这么多吗？
那买还是不买呢？
有人想三刀，
你这个人也太糾结了，
你都去两千块钱，
对于你来讲的话，
两千块钱，
你又不是拿工资吃饭的，
你是发工资的人，
你这两千块你都买不起嘛，
能买得起，
但是两个问题，
第一,
今年九月份，
是不是要上S12？
我就想问你，
S12是不是史上更新幅度最大的一代的，
这个苹果售表，
是不是，
你就回答我是不是，
那如果是，
我又不着急，
四个月我等不了吗？
我能等的呀，
我能等呀，
而且就算S12上了以后，
各平台都不打折，
那我也是有渠道拿员工价8，5折啊，
因为本身我跟大家节目里面讲过，
所以我的发小就是在苹果公司里面当这个相关，
这个管理层，
我们家苹果设备都是通过它来卖，
都是一上市就8，5折，
一上市就8，5折，
对吧，那这就没差多少钱，
那么现在的这个我看，
评论度上面的价格是2100多嘛，
是2001还是2003，
我记不得了，
两千多块钱，
就是我今天下单明天就能到嘛，
但是问题是，
我买东西就是这样子，
就是它到底有没有用，
它是不是刚需，
有人讲说你太扣，
其实我觉得不是扣，
是我给自己形成了一套消费的系统，
就是我做的每一件事情，
哪怕这个东西它的价格，
不是特别贵，
它是不是在我的这种，
行为模式里面，
是不是在我这个消费的这套系统里面，
它符合我的逻辑运转，
那我就把它列为我必消费的样品，
或者商品，
它如果不符合我的这个逻辑，
我就不做，
我就不买，
它哪怕再便宜，
再贵我都不买，
所以这是我的一种形式的风格，
你包括做节目也是一样的，
有人说这个热点，
那个热点要不要跟，
我的第一个评判标准就是，
它符不符合我的一贯的，
这种聊天的风格，
符不符合我的人设，
或者说我的整个的，
长久以往的立他的原则，
因为我的节目我更多的是希望能够，
让大家能够得到一些干货知识听的时候，
轻松一点，
然后啊啊啊啊啊啊啊原来这样啊原来那样，
如果我不听三道的节目，
这个知识点可能我不知道啊，
我不听三道节目不听三道节目可能这块我，
我在别别的短视频，
长视频的其他人账号里面，
我可能还一直不是很清楚，
那这不就是我存在的意义吗，
对吧跟大家来聊聊天，
老老科聊聊车，
聊聊生活，
聊聊身边是，
那顺便就是把这些事情给讲清楚了嘛？
对不对
那大家也了解了我。
也知道我是什么样一个人。
就ok了嘛？
所以新的原车其实现在变得越来越像电子产品。
消费品
那么围绕这个相关的数据。
还有权限的争议
未来只会是越来越多。
不会越来越少
好吧？
那么以上就是本期节目说的内容。
今天实在是不好意思。
因为我不知道怎么回事。
这两天嗓子有点哑。
有点感冒
因为打完篮球每次回家也不洗澡。
然后我就在那边就拿着个手机。
在沙发上面刷啊刷。
我媳妇也提醒我好多次。
我就这样
我说没事没事
结果四十多岁的人真不能这么硬扛。
我们家住的楼层又比较高。
然后阳台的窗户又开人。
小风吹吹还挺舒服的。
结果我就开始从早上留鼻子。
留鼻涕一直留到现在。
嗓子又有点哑
希望大家多多见谅。
那么听到最后的就是老体。
每期节目在评论区。
大家多多评论
每期我们会出取三位。
赠送由任严计提供的。
预录相离
实施装里面有五颗。
有人说任严计的颜。
到底是读颜还是读艳。
我问过他们老板了。
老板跟我讲就读颜。
就是任严计
没有任何问题
而且老板也听过我的节目。
如果我读错了
他很早就会提醒我了。
感谢感谢
评论区有人提醒我说。
你这个别读错了
就叫任严计
那么任严计
如果想买的话
你可以上小程序搜索摆车全说。
在我们的生辰里面就有。
非常好吃
真的你相信我
每一次保证回购
肯定很好吃的
然后下面就是小宇宙跟喜马拉雅。
如果没有订阅的兄弟们。
兄弟姐妹
因为我们知道
小宇宙有很多女婷友。
女性婷友
那么没有订阅的
可以用你的发财的小手点点订阅。
那么订阅数量其实对我很关键。
我们努力拼我
其实就是为了能够有更多的人。
能知道咱们的节目对吧？
那么还有就是像
隔壁的小石牛刀的节目。
你要是不够听
你可以去搜索
事情的是小石牛刀。
我跟我的好朋友们。
做了一些这种跨行业的对谈节目。
那么上期节目
我们聊的是特斯拉。
为什么选二线电视厂家。
星光达
这个二线其实打双引号的。
我特意打了个双引号。
其实不分什么一线二线。
但是你要从出货量。
各方面来讲的话
包括用户的薪质
就是你要让他选林德时代。
他肯定是不选星光达。
你说是不是
同样的价格
那么星光达
这个品牌
其实我们就不去讨论他好不好了。
因为好不好不是我们的说了算。
特斯拉也在用
iPhone
苹果公司也在用
你说还有什么好说的呢？
对吧？
跟极力之间的小摩擦。
只是一个我们所知道的可能。
很多的
有些车企也有这种摩擦。
只是没有把它公开化。
没有把这个官司放到新闻上。
只是我们知道了一件事。
仅此而已
上期节目有位听友叫做。
听友387985036。
他说我看到节目的标题。
我灰心一笑
本期节目继续聊特斯拉。
还是那个熟悉的三道。
还是初心未改的三道。
还是我们一直喜欢的三道。
不应外界纷扰
改变自己的表达
温柔自耻
自带风骨
内心藏着独一份的直扭。
与小叛逆
逆境千番人不改
本心坚守自清风
繁华乱世皆随波
唯有初心中不挪
这很有本采的一个兄弟。
其实说句实在话
我没想那么多
而且我说句可能你。
我不知道你是觉得。
我在开玩笑还是真的。
我是录节目录的一半。
我突然发现这期节目。
涉及特斯拉
因为这个节目
你这么理解
这个节目的脚本
其实在特斯拉那一期被下架之前。
就已经写好了
只不过一直没有拿上来用。
因为中间涉及到
包括有一些其他的新闻事件。
包括我试驾了一些新车。
我拿过来直接就说了。
那么拿过来用的这一天。
我当时反映就是
它是一个
这个新旺达被选中成为。
特斯拉的被选电池商的这么一个事件。
那么由此来讲一讲。
各家的电池之间的一些区别。
讲一讲这个电池相关的一些。
背后的技术
大家以后在选电车的时候能够。
有更多的干货
我是抱着这个初衷。
但是我都录了一半了。
我不能不录
所以我就坚持把它录完了。
所以你说的什么？
温柔自持自在风骨这个东西呢？
你说有没有
三刀我自认为有
但是有
只有那么一点
我其实本质上来讲还是一个。
这个独善其身的人吧？
我也不是君子
但也谈不上小人
就是属于
怎么说呢？
把自己的小日子过过好的人。
你要如果说
三刀有上去叫什么？
也不叫自私
叫做精致利己
这个时代我想问的是。
还有谁不精致利己啊？
都利他
都无私奉献
该无私奉献的时候。
我会无私奉献
但是你要看对什么人。
对于感恩的人
对于弱者
对于在公开环节
当着所有人的面的时候。
那我是一个无私奉献的人。
但是我说句实在话。
你要是背到别人背后。
我一个人
对吧？
人的内心
你说什么？
一定要什么慎读
就是讲句实在话慎读。
慎什么读啊？
关键门来什么无其八道的想法。
你没有啊？
你都是有的嘛？
你只是不说
不想
你能不能不做不好说。
关键门来的事情
谁知道呢？
家里面没监控
卫生间也没监控
谁知道你干点什么事呢？
是不是
所以
有些事情他
你知我只不用放在台面上去讲。
人也不用把人做得那么满。
像个白天鹅一样
别人给你铺脏水
你就感觉要死了
是吧？
要命了
没这个必要
洗干净了之后
你还是白天鹅
你干是谁还是谁
所以
没必要说什么？
三刀 温柔自食
自带风骨
没想那么多
哪怕就是下架了
下架了就下架了吧？
无所谓的对吧？
那我内心问心无愧。
我该做我也就做了。
对不对
其实我是非常跟着苗红的一个人。
但是
现在的互联网的分歧。
懂的都懂
是不是
得多都懂
下面一位厅友叫做。
厅友216850301。
他说国产电车用新网达。
大家会质疑
觉得这个车企用不起好东西。
特斯拉用新网达
诶
会被解读成新网达质量还行。
符合特斯拉的标准。
挺有意思
有什么挺有意思的呢？
那不非不就是说
消费者不懂电池吗？
无非不就是说消费者。
戴有色眼镜吗？
你想表达这个你也不敢说。
你还不是不敢说吗？
你说主播不敢讲
你别说主播了
评论区谁敢讲啊？
经常很多粉丝问提问问问题。
那问题就问个选车。
还要立名
他说三刀我这个问题。
有点隐私
我不太敢去公开
我在想
你连城市地址工作。
你什么都没提
你这有什么不敢说的呢？
你像如果我是一个粉丝。
我在我知识星球去发帖。
我如果只是一个ID。
你根本就不知道我是谁。
我什么不敢讲
我什么敢讲
我吐槽我的领导
我骂我的同事
对不对
我在上面去讲很多的新事。
把我的这个历任的前女友的故事。
我全部写一遍
你知道我是谁吗？
你又不知道
对吧？
那就是我的速度嘛？
所以我跟你讲
知识星球的兄弟们放开一点。
这就是朋友圈不能发系列。
没有人知道你是谁。
统共就那么几千个人。
三千多个人
而且这三千多个人也不是天天都上。
然后真正经常活跃的。
在一起玩的就那么几百号人。
这些人
这二八井就像兄弟姐妹一样。
以后有机会我一定要带兄弟们。
知识星球的兄弟们先下聚一聚。
非常好
有这么好的一个大的环境。
你有些什么心事
为什么不跟兄弟们姐妹们去聊一聊呢？
为什么不在这上面当成一个小树洞呢？
这是付了钱才能进的社群啊？
兄弟
谁会那么无聊说
我花了钱我还进来骂你两句啊？
谁会这样呢？
你没有这种地方是可以去讲的。
我讲句实在话
你在你朋友圈都是熟人。
对吧？
抖音
小红书
微博
你都不能发
因为就是广域平台。
你也说不定哪个熟人。
突然有钱就见到你看到你发的微博。
而且也说不定
那网上那都是乌七八糟的人。
你鬼知道那些广域的人。
广域流量的人会跟你说什么呢？
但这个里面
因为我三刀聚在一起。
大家有一些底层的共识。
他有一些底层的共识。
然后呢？
你再发一些心事
哎
你得到一些东西可能你更加能接受。
所以这知识星球经常会有人去。
问一些那种
家庭啊？
职场啊？
包括这种
就怎么样呢？
就是情感之方面的一些问题点。
我觉得真的兄弟们。
我就是看得挺感动的。
大家都四位谋面
但是
评论区里面
讲的都是真心的为他好。
真心的为大家好
好吧？
这又给我的知识星球宣传了一波。
感兴趣的话
添加微信
46415254。
找盾牌去加入就可以了。
好
我们再讲
最后一位挺友
叫
五爪草莓鱼
这个名字有点意思啊？
他说对于车企来讲。
一个零件的供应商。
应该叫供应商库
它最基本最健康的组合。
应该是2223
就是两家高端供应商。
两家中端供应商
三家低端供应商
这个高端车型可以让。
四家
也就是
这个两家高端跟两家中端的供应商竞争。
可以保证质量
中端或者是低端的车型可以用。
这个
是两家中端的供应商和。
三家的低端供应商去竞争。
那当然了
高端的供应商也可以参与。
但是一般情况下
它没有价格优势
但是呢电池这个行业啊？
它的供应商比较少。
它达不到223的组合。
其实特斯拉就是想按这个逻辑来。
不过能纳入五家供应商。
对于这种样子的这个级别的车型来讲。
那已经是非常多了。
感谢
把这个底层逻辑都说得很清楚了。
这绝对是业内人士啊？
绝对是绝对是这个。
管这个供应链的业内人士。
感谢啊？
所以我不说了嘛？
节目大家都是互相学习啊？
不是说大家在我这里学。
我也没什么东西可学的。
我跟大家也是在跟评论区的各位粉丝。
也是在学习行业内的知识。
共同成长
好的
那么？
以上就是本期节目所有的内容给大家收听啊？
今天嗓子不是很舒服。
再次表示抱歉啊？
那么我今天是在北京。
是在北京参加一个新车的试驾活动。
那么近期大家就能看到我的视频。
但是因为是保密协议。
哇
今天这台车子的保密协议。
违规的风险是多少啊？
一千万
违规的风险是一千万。
而且非常非常神奇的是什么？
就在
就是今天录节目的当天晚上。
就有相关的咨询公司。
他没有明说
他说我想给你调研一款新的原车。
一开始我说
调研新的原车可以啊？
我们加个微信联系一下。
结果加了微信之后。
他发给我的问题
我一看
他实际上就是想要我。
今天拿到的
就是
这个品牌
车型的最详细的信息。
然后给我钱
这个钱我能要吗？
百分之百是不能要的吗？
你开什么玩笑
你本管是以
图片的形式
文字的形式
哪怕你就是跟他打电话。
以音频的形式
都是会流痕
如果一旦要是流痕。
对方稍微要是
遇到一点那个什么事情。
把你的这个录音
截图传出去了
对不起
厂家那是真跟你打官司啊？
以前是五百万
现在是一千万
我肯定是不干这个事情的啊？
我肯定不干这个事情的。
今天我就看到有人。
肯定不是问我一个人。
但你说有没有胆子大的。
我猜应该是有胆子大的。
就是媒体施加
因为媒体施加也不是一波。
你要从今天开始陆陆续续的。
每隔一两天
就会有一批媒体过来。
去试这个车
所以你知道现在的这种。
新能源车企业之间的竞争有多激烈。
真的
明的暗的什么手段都伤了。
好的
那么以上就是节目所有的内容。
大家如果想看我更多的。
原创的视频
可以看这个比利比利的账号。
摆车全说
每周五有更新
还有就是短视频账号。
像抖音啊快手啊？
视频号小红书
都可以搜索三刀砍车。
单人旁砍大山的砍。
还有我个人微博
叫摆车全说
如果想看文章的话。
在我们的订阅号上。
摆车全说也可以看。
不仅仅文章视频也有。
还有就是我们的粉丝社群。
想要参加在社群里面。
一起去聊聊天
那么就可以添加微信。
4641-5254。
今天这期到这里
我们下期接着聊
拜拜